they are the shows that got us through
the pandemic and may keep us sitting on
our couch in the new year
it's okay y'all can sit and relax
welcome to entertainment tonight there
is so much good tv to binge and re-binge
tv also took us back to the wild wild
west with yellowstone yes a show i love
i mean and if kevin costner running a
ranch wasn't enough why not give us a
prequel starring tim mcgraw and faith
him
yes 1883 is officially here
a bath i imagine that y'all didn't need
much wardrobe for that bathtub scene
okay he wasn't much involved in that hey
you're right
now you said that scene was difficult
for you even though it's alongside your
husband it was a little difficult for
you because i'm modest 1883 fashion
she had the most trouble yeah the
corsets wow okay did you have marks on
your body when you take the corsets off
girl i have stories for days i had marks
ribs i had a rib at a place up here for
real i was playing an old shape
oh you should have planned harder what
was faith's reaction the first time she
saw bearded james dutton
i actually kind of like it although
anybody that knows me knows that my
beard is not this i have a graveyard so
we do some work on it but uh yeah i
think she kind of likes it this
yellowstone origin story just debuted
its first two episodes on paramount plus
it shows tim and faith as husband and
wife heading west for a better life i'm
gonna keep heading north until i find me
and it's worth the journey now you get
to be with her on set all the time all
the time all the time all the time
i'm kidding oh no it's that's what makes
it i mean i can't imagine spending five
months and her not being there with me
and being able to work together and do
the same thing and feed off each other
also in the cast sam elliott billy bob
thornton and surprise tom hanks did you
know in advance that tom was going to be
a part of this tom and rito and faith
and i've been friends for a long time so
i gave tom a call he goes tell me when
to be there and he killed him of course
he's trying hank so he's going to yeah
fans got their first taste of 1883 in
flashbacks featured in the current
season of yellowstone
and if everyone you know is telling you
to watch here's why number one kevin
costner
i think that's going to save you your
coward tv's most watched show with
nearly 8 million viewers per episode
definitely has action cowboy courage
when you're a little boy and you want to
be an actor what are what are some
things you want to play a cowboy a
soldier you know it's just kind of all
of the dream roles you know wrapped into
one and a very sexy romance when we did
our first scene you know we're having
sex on the uh the drawers yeah and
she slapped me across the face
i couldn't ask for a better partner this
relationship it it it's so powerful
because there's so much history to it
and i just love how he loves her one of
my favorite scenes of all time was when
he makes her breakfast in season three
you ever have fried bread
and how just simple an act of just
kindness
can just just set her into a very
vulnerable place your creation
yellowstone the number one show on tv
how does that feel you know it's
reaffirming that everyone in town passed
on it nobody wanted to make it
another new series in the taylor
sheridan universe mayor of kingstown
with jeremy renner
the drama on paramount plus follows
power brokers in the for-profit prison
business i said yes to this show without
reading one word of it what was it like
to prepare for this role i was always
ready and water was thrown at me every
day was exciting new adventure
back to yellowstone you can catch part
one of et's one hour special for
paramount plus right now and part two
premieres december 26th it is all to get
you ready for the finale on january 2nd
okay earlier we mentioned jeremy renner
has mayor of kingstown but fans of the
mcu well they are all about the return
of clinton barton aka
hawkeye
it's a big holiday event thing this is
happening it's it's a it's a real thing
i'll be able for christmas i promise
it's marvel's gift to all of us the
continuation of hawkeye's story after
avengers end game jeremy is hawkeye just
trying to celebrate christmas with his
family but his past keeps catching up
with him
it makes sense it makes it much more
family friendly um because you know
clint is a big family guy and the story
we're telling haley steinfeld co-stars
in the six episode mini-series as
hawkeye's overeager protege i'm
generally just pretty chill you know i'm
not like oh my god hawkeye
definitely not chill we baker and banter
quite a lot
look for lots of marvel easter eggs
throughout the series that's streaming
now on disney plus the final episode
drops tomorrow and there's even a
captain america show within the show it
was hysterical
it's something too
sad to watch
but if star wars is more your fandom get
ready for the book of boba fett i'm here
to make a proposal that's mutually
beneficial
yes the mandalorian spin-off that was
teased at the end of season two finally
hits disney plus december 29th tamara
morrison stars as the legendary bounty
hunter ming na wen reprises her role as
the mercenary who works for him if he
had spoken such insolence to jabba
he'd have fed you to his menagerie
you know now 2022 will also mark the
beginning of the end for two beloved
network shows the series finales of
blackish and also this is us
big three
three big
this three of friends has become a
family honestly they're my family and
and um
and so i will i'll keep in touch with
every single one of them so even though
the show's ending the group texts will
be intact
yeah i'll make sure of that yeah yeah i
don't know if you saw lit lyrics looking
like a grown started when she was seven
right like little grown girl i was like
put some clothes on i gotta tell you she
also said you'll probably be the most
emotional when they yell rap is that a
fair assessment come on man look i be
i'm cool you know what i'm saying i
don't i don't be getting too you know
worked up over this whole thing yeah
probably
as fans grab a box of tissues to start
saying goodbye to the pearsons january
4th on nbc the cast members are planning
on grabbing some things from the set
maybe one of my beards one of them one
of my fake mustaches something like that
that'd be kind of fun i want the i want
the piano
and i don't know if anybody else has
claimed it but i'm like how do i get it
out i'm gonna have to like do the
responsible thing and ask you've seen
your cast they got arms just collect
milo justin sterling help me with this
piano that's true chris
have you been eyeing things on set you
want to steal i probably take some of
the pictures because there's pictures of
the girls throughout the ages and i
remember season one i had to do a scene
where i picked them both up and carry
them i can't pick them girls up no more
are you excited to one day show gus your
son this show he's come to work with me
since he was like a month old so he's
seen me in different makeup and wigs you
have the same voice but you look like
you're 70. that's gonna be a fun
experience to look back on photos or
therapy
blackish is also gearing up for their
eighth and final season premiering
january 4th they begin their farewell
with a special guest michelle obama
we wrapped a couple weeks ago but it was
bittersweet that turned to sadness but
we we managed the tears to be together
for eight years to to watch these
children grow to spend more time with my
television wife than i did with my real
life wife uh you know yeah it it's it's
it's sad to uh to not be able to get up
in the morning and go to see these same
faces every day but you know we we've uh
we've established a friendship a bond in
the family that that will never be
broken i love you i love you so much
the kids have just become these
beautiful human beings and it's it was
an honor when we started they were so
talented but they've become family did
you leave with any mementos
a lot of things close took some clothes
walked
not
available
[Music]